that is with us in Saginaw Michigan hi
Annette how are you sir I'm good how are
you today
better than I deserve what's up
excellent I'm a bit concerned about the
departure of England from the EU and the
potential financial difficulties that
that might cause as well as concerned
about the high debt ratio that our large
banking institutions globally are
carrying I was going to ask about gold
but I just heard you talk about the
celebrity selling that what do you
recommend as a more conservative form of
investment based on you know day
volatility of what's going on out there
in our are you concerned about
volatility due to those things are
collapsed due to those things maybe a
little bit of both you know there's
always the fear about total global
collapse and you know or even a major
downturn in our economy like we saw in
2008 and so I just wanted a little
direction
Johnson okay um well let's cover the the
second one first a major downturn or
volatility due to those things the
global picture or do even two things
like our national spending and our
national debt which is freaking out of
control we would all agree and there's
volatility associated with all of those
there's there is that those things are
all destabilizing to the a the world
economy and B the US economy and a lot
of and even the banks being leveraged
like they are are destabilizing
obviously the banks got in trouble and
that's what with bad mortgage you know
definitions you know treating treating
subprime mortgages like they were prime
and securitizing and such and it caused
a huge drop in o8 now but here's the
thing from a consumer investment
viewpoint in Oh 8 I was invested in good
growth stock mutual funds in the stock
market and I was invested in real estate
I did not cash out a dime of that in
either case due to that drop in o 8 as a
matter of fact I continued buying both
mm-hmm cuz I made millions of dollars
extra doing that I didn't make million
but I made pretty good well like while
it was going down you bought right yeah
exactly
and so the volatility worked to our
benefit instead of to our detriment
using those vehicles to invest in okay
and so I actually enjoy a little bit of
positivity if I'm willing to ride it out
okay and if it's not the ultimate thing
now and then the run the other scenario
which is complete meltdown in collapse
of a global economy or a US economy
there's not a financial instrument gold
included that will protect you against
that because what happens is on you know
you can go back to Argentina you can go
back to pre Hitler Germany one of the
things that put Hitler into power and
cause the fascists to take over was a
meltdown of their economy that
hyperinflation he's a wheelbarrow full
of money to buy a loaf of bread exactly
and and it destroyed their economy and
so they had to hit a reset cold reset on
the entire German government yeah and
they completely started over they wiped
the whole thing clean and so the the
medium of exchange their markets
everything was gone and they just
started fresh and so fascism came in and
and when you look what happens is in a
meltdown scenario then you start at the
whole country over and there's none of
the financial instruments survived and
that includes gold an example of that
the most recent one is different reasons
would be like Iraq okay I have cool
pieces of paper with Saddam Hussein's
faces on them that used to be called
money mm-hm
but not after his Hamid Saddam Hussein
was gone oh he has no longer a medium of
exchange a big pile of that is worthless
now you know if you had a big pile of
gold in that scenario could you have
come out probably you'd been a better
often having a pile of that paper but
but generally gold is not used in within
that economy as a medium of exchange in
those situations other things are the
first thing that happens in a complete
meltdown is barter system erupts okay
and so having things that you want to
trade with you know commodities would be
more valuable so I am not planning for
any of that because I don't foresee that
I'm a glass-half-full guy and I yes
there's problems out there and those are
going to bring volatility I'll go with
you on that I am NOT prepping for a
meltdown if you really want to
completely prep for a meltdown it be
generators bottled water guns and
bullets and that preps you for a
complete meltdown better than bars of
gold does not only can you protect
yourself and survive but you can also
got stuff to trade this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 in
common